yo what was it like being a part of the
Black Panther soundtrack because that
kind of was a moment yeah Kendrick was
on that record too yeah that's a big
deal now first of all not a lot of
people these days sharing records with
Kendrick and that's one of the biggest
movies of all time so that's my biggest
song to this day that [__] went
like double platinum in that
[__] just a song at seven ain't
got no videos no video nothing I feel
like that was kind of like the last
hurray for SOB kinda yeah that was like
our biggest I feel like after that [__]
is when [__] kind of started uh yeah man
a lot of [__] started happening man
behind the scenes you know how that [__]
go man just some old brother [__] though
[__] fighting behind the scenes like
we brothers and we was young you know
how that [__] go like but what was that
moment like for you like just kind of
knowing you met you're making it onto a
Marvel movie soundtrack and and
Kendrick's hopping on the record I ain't
gonna lie when we first got in the
studio we got on that [__] like
I really ain't think it was gonna really
come out he's like yep at least got the
chance to be in the studio with that
[__] and give us what oh you guys are
in the studio with him hey we got the so
[__] really just had to mindset like
[__] at least we got up in the studio
and got the chance to defend me show
that [__] what we got for real you fan
and it's a banger but when that [__]
came out
I heard the uh Black Panther [__] came
out but [__] Ain't really think you
sent me our [__] was on there so I
really didn't even check like
[__] was just calling a [__]
like yo you make the Black Panther
soundtrack y'all [__] going crazy
[__] your first one stupid I'm like
hell nah I'm in the studio at the time
too recording I go straight to the
soundtrack I listen to that [__] the way
he put the little pause on my [__] I was
like oh I ain't gonna lie like that [__]
then they're like gave a [__]
Goosebumps right you feel me the way
that that [__] hit a [__] with the the
boy you feel me then change the tempo
for like four bars like I ain't gonna
lie that [__] had a [__] feeling like a
champion you know like when you growing
up a [__] got you you in sports you
wanted trophies and [__] when I was
playing sports like online really win
too many trophies right like I was
really a street ball player I wouldn't
really you feeling me one of the ones
really really on the court so you family
[__] like that like that's a trophy for
me do you ever kind of because I saw uh
Lil G just got sentenced to some serious
prison time
um and we think kind of like
everybody kind of went their own way
when it came to the group it feels like
you're kind of the one guy who's kind of
cut through and like been able to really
be consistent and really kind of show
improve as a solo artist
um a shout out to Young Teo he's up you
know he's obviously had some dope solo
[__] too but for you like uh
not knowing your personal relationship
with these guys anymore but do you tap
in with somebody like Lil G if he you
know gets he has to go sit down for 20
years like just on someone like you said
some brothership or is that relationship
kind of a rap
slimming my brother
and that's it it's let me my brother
that's fair who's gonna be on the EP
uh [__] really just Kayla for real for
real for real I can't wait to hear that
yeah Mama's you know I'm trying to push
that I'm trying to push that one uh
man I'm trying to gain my my lady fan
base you family so he's on the hook uh
yeah for sure yes sir was there
something you guys got in the studio
together on yeah yep I caught that [__]
that [__] pulled up laid that [__]
down lay my [__] down boom classic it's
one of the ones too on my mama yo speak
to me because uh Max race from Vallejo
and obviously you know one of the more
celebrated artists to come out of the
bay especially if you're from the bay
did you go up listening to Mac Dre were
you or was he I mean that was kind of
like past your generation a bit like was
that something that you just kind of had
to go back
his music was always around like of
course like [__] knew like all the all
the big [__] like even like even like
the big the songs that was like big in
the streets like [__] knew mostly of
them like most of that [__] though like
I really had to go back and go you see
me dig do my own little researching for
real when I was young like I was really
into [__] like
like I was really into like the
mainstream [__] like Lil Wayne Like of
course a young [__] at that time like
Soulja Boy like I had to really do my
own digging I knew the main [__] though
but like to hear him on his gangster
[__] like when he first came out oh
you're like really [__] yeah yeah I had
to go do my own research for sure I do
feel like you guys kind of influenced a
generation of I feel like
SOB y'all probably don't get as a group
the credit you deserve in terms of you
guys influenced a lot of La guys yeah
for so I feel like a lot of like how you
guys are rapping the flow y'all had like
kind of the slightly offbeat [__] like I
feel like you guys kind of
and this can be said about the Bay Area
in general with a lot of [__] that
happens
you guys influence a lot of [__] but
don't necessarily get the credit for the
influence that you guys have on hip-hop
even La hip-hop do you guys did you guys
notice that like happening because you
guys are the hottest [__] moving and a
lot of people in La started to pop up
that in my opinion sounded a lot like
what you guys are doing yeah did you
notice that yeah for so you know how
that [__] go like we don't really you
know how that [__] go like we don't
really get no we don't get credit for a
lot of [__] but you feel me like [__]
not gonna hit the scene cry about it and
pout for real I mean like it is what it
is at the end of the day though a lot of
[__] that you feel me a lot of [__]
I run into like they're paying [__]
homage like when they see a [__] but
like [__] probably not just gone ain't
nobody's gonna want to put it out there
like oh [__] I ain't gonna lie
I I relieve like [__] really base my
flow off the young [__] like we young
[__] like maybe if we was like
some OG's or something in the game like
[__] it'd be easier to pay
homage to be like oh I really been grew
up listening young [__] you feel me
don't know about it not too many
[__] want to give a young [__]
too much credit you feel me they think a
young [__] big-headed oh they don't
want to give a a young [__] that much
juice that much power but [__] don't
be you family like I think it's be on
some humble [__] [__] not really
tripping off that [__] like it is what
it is like like I can't think of you
guys and I think like Shoreline Mafia
had like a lot of
Sons like this kind of yeah so you gotta
remember like one [__] might
copy us and then the [__] that
copied us a [__] might have
copied them I do not even not listen to
our [__] starting me like it's just it's
just so much recycled [__] going on you
don't know who a [__] really
getting [__] from like we started a lot
of [__] but like a lot of [__] got
recycled like you feel me like
[__] get it's like lost files
like [__] don't know where they
got this in that front right it's all
good though like I'm glad to see that
[__] credit away for everybody
to eat for real cause a lot of the young
[__] scene was dead it wasn't no young
[__] really rapping for real like we
taught young [__] how to talk [__] you
feel me just be free you feel me uh
speaking mind it's a lot of cappers up
on this [__] too that you feel they
making no way though you feel me
congratulate them boys
feeding a lot of young [__] off the
wave and a [__] started but I
ain't gonna say [__] we all
started this [__] as a group but right
you feel me like they ain't tripping out
that [__] let them boys go crazy